imágenes de un bote con migrantes
cubanos Y haitianos
llega a las costas del estado de la
Florida la guardia costera de Estados
Unidos acaba interceptar esta
embarcación una escena constante que
refleja la magnitud del actual crisis
migratoria
hace unos años veíamos solo un barco con
migrantes cada mes o dos meses ahora
vemos cuatro o cinco embarcaciones
diariamente
frente al aumento de migrantes la ley
Estatal es Clara inadmitirlos en Florida
y transportarlos hacia otros estados del
país norteamericano congresista
republicanos festejaron una ampliación
de esta ley promovida por el gobernador
republicano ronde santis y aprobada en
2022 Agradecido por el liderazgo de Paul
Runner y del gobernador ron de santis me
siento honrado de apoyarlos en nuestro
trabajo por solucionar un problema que
creó Washington ong como Florida y
migrante y activistas por los derechos
de los migrantes denuncian que la
ampliación de esta ley no solo es
xenófoba sino corrupta Florida pagó un
millón y medio de dólares por el truco
de los vuelos de migrantes de ron de
santis el año pasado ahora los
legisladores acaban de votar para dar
otros 10 millones de dólares a este
estúpido teatro político este dinero se
destina a empresas mediante contratos
sin licitación que donan a campañas
republicanas esto no sólo es cruel es
una estafa gigante
en septiembre de 2022 el estado de Texas
ya había aplicado políticas similares
cuando 48 migrantes en su mayoría
venezolanos fueron trasladados a
Massachusetts la crisis migratoria se ha
convertido en una batalla política entre
republicanos y demócratas